et deux mecs qui s'engueulent mais très
fort il y en a ils disent à l'autre il
dit Jean-Pierre Jean-Pierre pourquoi
quoi
ta couche avec elle Jean-Pierre [ __ ]
merde j'ai oublié
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi
il dit écoute elle était toute nue
devant moi
voilà on était seul
bon j'étais censé faire quoi et le DJ le
top 6
[Applaudissements]
je pense que ma femme est devenue sourde
ah bah l'autre j'ai dit attends je vais
te donner un tuyau pour être sûr et pour
savoir la vérité tu sais ce que tu fais
que tu rentres ce soir
appelle ta franchi la porte tu dis à
haute voix chérie qu'est-ce qu'on mange
toi si elle te répond pas tu progresses
dans la maison tu vas dans la pièce où
se trouve ta femme carrément la cuisine
par exemple tu rentres dans la cuisine
et là tu redis à haute voix chérie casse
qu'on mange toi si elle répond toujours
pas
tu viens derrière elle 50 cm derrière
elle tu mets tes mains comme ça et tu
dis
qu'est-ce qu'on mange et si elle répond
pas c'est qu'elle est sourde mec qui dit
d'accord il rentre franchit la porte
qu'est-ce qu'on mange rien à la cuisine
et ce moment il va derrière sa femme
qu'est-ce qu'on mange et là sa femme
elle se retourne et elle lui dit pour la
troisième fois des lasagnes
maman je ne veux pas aller à l'école ça
on a compris
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi et ben parce que ils sont
méchants avec moi ce mec de Moi Moche
dessus et me jette des pierres
Jean-Pierre tu es le proviseur de ce
lycée de Bayard
ça se passe bien
de boutiques de luxe et tout et tout ça
parce que sinon vous baissez la tranche
de Gladys quand on est micro c'est tout
simplement rigide c'est une tranche ABC
merci vas-y mon mari
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs la plus luxueuse de Paris
d'accord et voilà il y a un camion noir
6 heures du matin carré il se garde
devant la vitrine de chez Cartier le
hayon s'ouvre l'éléphant énorme un
éléphant attends Jean-Marie on va la
refaire parce que il y avait un problème
tu as déjà perdu ta mère
[Applaudissements]
l'éléphant fonce dans la vitrine de chez
Cartier il est casse la vitrine bien sûr
avec sa trompe et bijoux il remonte et
remonté dans le camion et le camion il
part le commissaire arrive deux heures
plus tard et il dit au seul témoin de la
faire c'est un petit garçon de café qui
installe sa terrasse qu'est-ce que vous
avez vu je raconte il y a un gros camion
noir l'éléphant a cassé à Vitré elle a
piqué bijoux on monte un camion le
camion est parti
et le commissaire il dit vous avez le
l'immatriculation du camion vous avez
noté
c'est une blague ou quoi
dis comment on dit j'assiste un truc
complètement dingue ni vous croyez que
je me suis amusé à regarder la plaque du
camion dis non bien sûr que non moi il
dit le marque du camion non plus bah il
dit bien sûr
non plus qu'est-ce que vous me pétez les
couilles alors là le commissaire
il lui dit mais dites-moi quand même
monsieur vous pouvez peut-être quand
même me dire si c'était un éléphant
d'Afrique
pour un éléphant d'Asie
de ma gueule j'habite à Sarcelles moi
qu'est-ce que j'y connais
et là le commissaire Lucie il est en
colère il vous savez très bien ce que je
veux dire c'est très bien que l'éléphant
d'Afrique il y a des grandes oreilles
l'éléphant d'Asie il a des petites
oreilles ah ben dis là je peux pas vous
dire il avait une cagoule
tu m'achètes une blague nous en rappelle
c'est le problème
et il s'est tout allongé il se couche
dans le plumard et il meurt tu vois
aussitôt et là il arrive vers
Saint-Pierre tu vois et donc
Saint-Pierre il lui l'autre il dit il
m'a dit c'est quoi l'histoire je suis
mort c'est ça j'ai bien compris je suis
mort décédé quoi
il dit non non il y a pas un moment
moi je veux pas mourir moi moi je veux
retourner sur Terre maintenant très en
colère Saint-Pierre bon et prend en
compte le Kourou du du mec qui dit
écoutez monsieur c'est pas normal moi je
fais ça depuis des siècles et des
siècles on peut pas revenir comme ça ou
alors
il aurait bien une solution mais dis
quoi allez-y dis je pourrais vous faire
revenir mais ce serait en animal quoi il
dit oui il dit en ce moment j'ai que
poule
il y a pas d'autre choix c'est pour le
midi je m'en ok je reviens en poule il y
a pas de problème je revenais je
retrouve en poule
dans la basse-cour
le coq il arrive il vient avant il dit
bonjour madame la poule
et dis vous êtes la nouvelle comment ça
va et ben elle dit ça va ça va mais si
je vous disais je me sens un petit peu
barbouillé quoi tu peux j'ai mal au
ventre à coque il dit c'est parce que
vous allez répondre à un œuf
certainement je suis un spécialiste vous
pouvez me croire et vous croyez dit oui
oui dis allez-y madame la poule poussez
poussez vous allez pondre un œuf pour
tous ces pousses
qui sort le coq qui dit voyez je vous
l'avais dit c'était un œuf ça va mieux
et la poule elle dit bah ça va mieux ça
va mieux
je suis encore un petit peu
mal au ventre a dit ça ça c'est un
deuxième œuf ça arrive des fois par deux
et dialyse pousser madame la poule vous
êtes une poule poussée allez-y
c'est un deuxième œuf qui arrive tu vois
et à ce moment-là le mec qui prend une
grande tarte dans la gueule par sa femme
elle lui dit oh c'est pas bientôt fini
de chier dans le plumard
[Applaudissements]
en fait les enfants alors le vrai a dit
tu sais bien maman nous l'a dit j'ai
expliqué les garçons ils naissent dans
les choux et les filles Inès dans les
roses et c'est la cigogne qui amène
toujours les enfants la petite fille
elle dit oui j'ai entendu toutes ces
conneries là mais la cigogne il y a
quand même quelqu'un qui la baise à un
moment donné
ah bah non on va le mec il est dans la
chambre et avec sa femme il entend du
bruit dans l'armoire disons
il ouvre l'armoire il voit un mec à poil
dans l'armoire il dit monsieur
tu comprends le mec ah bah oui il dit
Monsieur cachez vous faites là vas-y je
chasse les mythes
ez-vous chasser les mythes à poil et
l'autisme regarde que c'est Dieu [ __ ]
elles m'ont déjà tout bouffé
j'ai envie de te faire l'amour sa femme
a dit bah oui mais chérie ça tombe mal
parce que en ce moment j'ai des pertes
blanches et le mec il dit bah c'est pas
grave moi j'ai du diabète on va faire
des meringues
qui est persuadé que sa femme le trompe
tu vois et donc il décide de rentrer à
l'improviste c'est-à-dire il rentre à
13h il rentre jamais à 13h c'est jamais
arrivé de sa vie toi très très énervé il
habite au 15e étage d'une tour tu vois
et il rentre monte dans l'ascenseur il
est comme ça il est sûr qu'il va la
pécho tu vois il ouvre la porte en furie
et ça ça tombe pile trouve sa femme dans
le couloir à poil toute transpirante tu
vois et lui dit il est où il est où cet
[Applaudissements]
fouille partout il va dans la chambre
sur le lit sous le lit il ouvre toutes
les armoires tout le bois il trouve rien
toi et à un moment il se souvient que du
haut de son 15e étage
il a la chance de voir un petit balcon
tu vois avec une porte-fenêtre comme ça
je dirigea porte fenêtre et il ouvre et
là il le voit
il est là le mec il est agrippé on
partait comme ça avec
étage en dessous de lui
dire [ __ ] et lui tape sur les doigts
toi le mec il lâche pas quand il tient
il tient toi
il prend une chaise pour être un peu
plus haut lui piétine les doigts
avaient-ils le mec continue à tenir
[Applaudissements]
la maison il va dans sa caisse à outils
pour un marteau et lui pète tous les
doigts les uns les autres
à la fin le mec qui tient plus que par
le petit doigt comme ça
il lâche il tombe de 15 étages
heureusement
il y a trois ou quatre arbres bien
serrés en dessous
qui tu le crois tu le crois pas qui lui
amortisse sa chute
4 5 branches et il est immobilisé avant
de toucher le sol l'autre en haut et
regarde tu es bouge encore s'encule
[Rires]
il attrape le frigidaire c'est un
monstre le frigidaire il prend en parole
souvent ça
[Applaudissements]
les veines qui gonfle et se lever sur
les dents et papa il va vers la porte
fenêtre je traverse le petit balcon il
bute dans la rambarde le frigo passe
au-dessus lui il tombe sur la gueule du
mec donc le mec meurt
il arrive chez Saint-Pierre
si c'est important vous allez voir pour
la suite et
ding dong
il raconte il dit voilà j'étais sûr que
ma femme me trompais je suis rentré à
l'improviste et ça a pas loupé je suis
tombé dessus voilà alors bon j'ai fait
un truc pas très sympa je le dis tout de
suite Saint-Pierre c'est vrai mais qui
était accroché par rappel du balcon et
il dit j'ai été jusqu'à prendre un
marteau j'ai pété tous les doigts
jusqu'à ce qu'il a chipie cet [ __ ] là
il bougeait encore
elle était bloquée par les arbres donc
j'ai pris le frigo et je lui ai foutu
sur la gueule donc Saint-Pierre il dit
bah écoutez mettez-vous là à côté dit
c'est pas banal que l'histoire ni
asseyez-vous je vais vous prendre tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
et là il y a un autre mec qui se qui se
pointe il dit et vous monsieur qui si
vous arrivez bah écoutez moi je suis
peintre en bâtiment
si vous voulez jeter en train de
repeindre un balcon au 17e étage
d'une tour je vais presque fini mon
travail il me restait une petite
retouche à faire à l'extérieur
je me suis penché la peinture était
fraîche donc glissante tu vois et
je suis tombé mais grâce à Dieu je sais
pas par quel miracle j'ai réussi à me
rattraper au balcon du 15e étage
et dit là j'ai vu un mec arrivé vers moi
en furie
les yeux exorbitaires et au lieu de
m'aider au lieu de m'aider
ok il m'a tapé sans les doigts il y a un
moment elle a pris un marteau et il m'a
pété tous les noirs et je suis tombé
grâce à Dieu aussi je suis tombé sur un
art très touché très gentil
qui m'a empêché de m'écraser au sol je
me suis dit merci mon Dieu j'avais pas
fini de penser ça le mec qui m'a envoyé
un frigo de 2 tonnes en pleine tête et
je suis
morte
du monsieur hein je vais vous prendre
une
fenêtre retentit à nouveau Jean-Pierre
dit mais c'est une série ce matin ou
quoi
disez-vous Monsieur que si vous arrivez
et là le mec il dit que tu es moi j'ai
rien compris
j'étais caché à poil dans un frigidaire
[Applaudissements]